[Musique]
nous assistons au déploiement militaire
russe le plus agressif de son histoire
j'ai ordonné la 6e soit envoyer un
sous-marin d'attaqué
genre d'homme de traverser des meilleurs
qu'aucun sous marin américain n'a encore
jamais traversé immergé l'appareil
[Musique]
on a surveillé le président russe et son
ministre de la défense
c'est un coup d'état et si en libérer le
président aka règle et nous on sauve le
président russe on va y aller avec
quatre de nos gars ne sont pas entraînés
pour ce genre d'émission si on ne
réussit pas ses missions il y aura le
troisième guernica
c'est à cuirassé
torpillant approche pour poste qu'il
adore vivre us
pour l'ansés
il retire
e